Ehi non puoi entrare nel mio percorso
dovrei farlo da capo
questa
per un pelo
[Musica]
Bruno della ragione Siamo stati
intrappolati in questa prigione dal
poliziotto cattivo lo dobbiamo riuscire
a scappare e a prendere il badge per
vincere questa Challenge di Roblox nella
vita reale Sì ma è già passata un'ora di
pranzo non vorrei andare a cercare il
badge senza aver mangiato prima no non
pensare a mangiare adesso dobbiamo
riuscire a trovare un piano per scappare
Aspetta un secondo ma facciamo una gara
a chi prende prima il mezzo sì anzi ho
una Challenge per voi lasciate un mi
piace se ti fate per me e iscrivetevi se
ci fate per Vitale buona presto troviamo
una soluzione per scappare Che cosa c'è
qua in questa prigione c'è qualcosa C'è
solo questo guarda
No non vedo altro
sono stato io a chiamarlo
aiuto
è colpa tua mi sa che sei arrabbiato
perché ho suonato questa trombetta
[Musica]
arriveranno
mi ha detto di stare zitto a me come
faccio a stare zitto Io praticamente mi
ha indicato le chiavi ha detto che non
usciremo da qui senza quelle chiavi Sì
infatti quello che dobbiamo fare è
riuscire a rubargli le chiavi per aprire
il lucchetto e scappare da questo primo
stage nella prigione
ma Ah ma a rubargli le chiavi Adesso
provo questa Trombetta e vediamo che
cosa succede
[Musica]
premendo quel pulsante c'è quella
Trombetta Sei riuscito a far uscire un
oggetto un topolino forse la chiave per
scappare da qua Ma come però
voglio dire un'idea ora prendo il
topolino e poi chiamami il poliziotto
sta a vedere aspetta Sei sicuro che è
una buona idea Non credo che sia una
buona idea chiamare poliziotto adesso si
è rovinato tantissimo almeno Nascondilo
quel Topolino Ma che cosa vuoi fare non
ti preoccupare adesso lo nascondo e poi
lo chiamo pronti
Dobbiamo trovare il modo per distrarlo
non lo so farlo addormentare guarda
e adesso e adesso la faccio cadere
No no no no
[Applauso]
non ci
posso credere riesci a prenderle Adesso
ci provo
Dai dai Devo riusci
RCI
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Te l'avevo detto di darmi le chiavi Hai
visto cosa è successo visto che non mi
hai voluto liberare hai perso una vita
cosa impari non lo sapevo
per arrivare
adesso Dammi le chiavi mi libero prima
io
Sì si è aperto il lucchetto stai aperto
Sì sono libera dalla mia Nutella
preferiresti pure la mia dicella per
favore secondo voi dovrei aprire Vitale
oppure faccio come ha fatto lui lo
lascia qua dentro così vado a prendere
il badge
Vitale io ho perso pure una vita
Vabbè Siccome io sono più brava d'Italia
Lo aprirò così continuiamo la Challenge
assieme eh Sì esatto Brava hai fatto
bene Anita Sbrigati prima che arriva la
guardia Uh ho aperto anche la tua sella
Grazie Perfetto non è ancora finita
dobbiamo passare al prossimo stage
abbiamo detto
[Musica]
prossimo stage Wow Che cosa dobbiamo
fare
credo che dobbiamo arrivare lì fino alla
fine del percorso Ah bene ma queste A
cosa servono ma non serviranno a niente
non credo che non servono a niente Ti
sei appena sfracellato Sì forse dobbiamo
infilare le gambe qua e riuscire a
saltare fino alla giù fino al Check
Point con questi sacchi certo la corsa
col sacco
[Musica]
è molto più difficile di quello che
pensassi Sì è vero
Ehi
non puoi razzo
Oh no devo rifarlo da capo così impari a
entrare nel mio percorso arrivo prima io
prima io prima io
[Musica]
siamo di nuovo da capo
non è giusto scherzetto scherzetto
arrivo
[Risate]
no no no no no
oh Uffa adesso Vitale in vantaggio devo
raggiungerlo
e adesso sono io in vantaggio a vincere
io sicuramente sono troppo avanti
è troppo difficile questo gioco
riproviamoci per l'ultima volta sono in
vantaggio sto per vincere
Sono quasi al traguardo Non ci puoi
credere Guarda dietro girati non mi fido
secondo vuoi farmi distrarre per vincere
ma che
per un pelo
no
[Musica]
Ehi aspetta un momento mi sono stancata
di sfracellarmi così tante volte e se
proviamo a fare il percorso senza avere
il cucchiaio e questo uovo in bocca e
Prova ad andare direttamente lì anche
perché là c'è un nastro rosso
sicuramente dobbiamo prendere quel
nastro rosso per vincere la Challenge
Beh io vado ciao ciao
[Musica]
Adesso ti faccio vedere io a Vitale
Beccati questo
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta
sia quello nuovo
delle Armi strane Guarda c'è il
bersaglio lì dobbiamo fare centro e
vediamo chi fa più punti comincia tu dai
cominciamo Ok vado prima
[Musica]
Dai Provaci ancora Oh dai ce le cose
ancora
no Quanti punti ho fatto perché 60 No ho
fatto solo due punti nell'80 quindi 160
Vediamo se Vitale riuscirà a battermi in
questa Challenge e adesso tocca a me
[Musica]
[Risate]
sono in vantaggio solo per questo round
Adesso le facciamo un altro e vediamo
Ora secondo round Ma sarà molto più
difficile nuova modalità
[Musica]
è difficile
220 punti Bravo
Allora due da 80 e uno da 60 più 120
vediamo ora Vitale Quanti punti riesce a
fare e adesso tocca a me
Buonanotte
sono ancora una due
hai fatto tutta la puzzi
ma ora è il momento del terzo round
[Musica]
Questo è il round decisivo
[Applauso]
l'ultimo
Wow Vediamo quanti punti ha fatto paura
da 80 e uno da 60 140 punti Vediamo
adesso Vitale Quanti punti fa Tocca a me
[Musica]
anch'io due palline
140 punti uno da 80 euro da 60 e ho
vinto io questo Space ma ora passiamo
subito al prossimo il prossimo pesce
[Musica]
Siamo in un nuovo stage che cosa
dobbiamo fare qua vediamo esplorare Ehi
aspetta che voi avete lasciato mi piace
se questo video raggiunge i 10.000 mi
piace uscirà un nuovo video Escape Room
Mi raccomando
volevo uscire fuori per vedere se c'era
qualcosa da fare però se la porta è
chiusa vuol dire che dobbiamo sbloccare
il prossimo stage oppure dobbiamo
provare a aprire quella di Porta Hai
ragione
E allora dobbiamo fare qualcosa
ma quelli dobbiamo farli vedere con cosa
è semplice ci basterà premere il tasto 1
e le armi che abbiamo preso sono le
stage precedenti ci appariranno
Sì abbiamo i nostri le nostre armi
allora chi provava
Allora vado
io adesso perché tipo se ci riesco Uno
due tre
Boh Hahaha
non ho toccato niente
ah ah
Vitale non ho beccato niente lo stesso
Pensavo fosse più semplice questa
Challenge in realtà ma è un po'
difficile Esatto
ora due tre
no no no ti fa vedere tutti adesso
dobbiamo beccare anche gli altri
[Musica]
avvita la ho finito i colpi Non ho
beccato un bel niente provo io
Guarda C'era una chiave nascosta qua tra
i bicchieri sicuramente la chiave aprirà
una delle due porte oppure tutte e due
le porte possiamo passare al prossimo
stage bravissima di Top Grande sei
troppo brava Aspetta però in quale porta
andiamo e quello No secondo me dobbiamo
andare in quella forse
Secondo voi quale porta dobbiamo andare
di quella Vabbè io vado in quella è
quella la porta
prossimo sta
Ge il mio sesto senso mi dice che è
questa è una scorciatoia e quindi sarò
in vantaggio e arriverò prima di Anita
al badge quindi andiamo da questa parte
anche se adesso mi è venuto un dubbio il
mio sesto senso per volta non funziona
bene quando non mangio Ah non fa niente
Non fa niente andiamo da questa parte
così magari arriverò prima a prendere il
Belgio e prima arriverò a mangiare
andiamo
Oh no non era una scorciatoia era
ricomincia il gioco da capo Sono
ritornato nella prigione E adesso come
farò da solo senza la vita no
Aiuto non succede niente qui Anita
Oh finalmente guarda vieni qua guardiamo
Ascolta praticamente mi sono accorto Uhm
No no aspetta un attimo Non urlare
Innanzitutto
ho sbagliato ho sbagliato ovunque
pensavo fosse una scorciatoia invece mi
sono ritrovato qui eh adesso mi devi
riportare dove stavo prima riporta
mi sta prendendo in giro mi sta
prendendo Mi devi riportare dove stavo
prima ho sbagliato pensavo fosse una
scorciatoia invece
non voglio stare zitto io
niente mi ha preso pure in giro con la
guardia E adesso come faccio a Rita Oh
no la vita sarà già andata avanti negli
stage e magari Adesso proviamo
Io adesso qui Ah ah ah ah
oh no ma Vitale non c'è è davvero andato
in quell'altra porta non posso fidarmi a
lasciarlo da solo potrebbe essersi
cacciato in qualche altro guaio E va
bene torno indietro e passo anch'io da
quell'altra porta e vediamo in quale
stage ci porta Ok era questa la porta da
cui è passato Vitale andiamo
Ma dove dove
abita Vitale Ma allora hai seguito il
percorso che ho fatto anch'io
ti amo
all'inizio del gioco
Guarda io praticamente pensavo che
questo fosse un po' una scorciatoia
invece
sulla strada per ricominciare da capo ha
detto Come facciamo però aspetta aspetta
c'è una cosa positiva e tutto questo
abbiamo le nostre armi Ti ricordi quelle
che abbiamo preso prima e le possiamo
utilizzare adesso no Ah è vero meno male
almeno abbiamo conservato un qualcosa
dagli stage precedenti e quindi che cosa
facciamo ora mettiamo KO il poliziotto
con questa
se ne accorgerà se si accorgerà che
abbiamo quest'arma non ci darà mai la
chiave dobbiamo riuscire a metterlo capo
e poi rubargli la chiave Hai qualche
idea e certo che ho un piano Anita
adesso guarda lo chiamo e poi ti faccio
vedere
Guarda guarda
eh Ma che fai nascondi l'arma sono il
poliziotto della sequenza
[Musica]
così via Eh sì anche lei si è sbagliata
ah ah ah ah ah ah
perché arriva così tanto e certo che
ride perché sei stato così intelligente
da questo poliziotto qual
allora eh Non ti preoccupare Anita è che
devo sparare un colpo ma al momento
giusto non ti preoccupare Aspetta un
attimo
ah ah
sì sì Tanto poi vediamo che ride per uso
No perché non apri questo visto che fa
il gatto eh Eh sì sì ah sì sì lo devi
aprire tu
adesso
[Musica]
lo stordito
ha funzionato prendi le chiavi
Dai presto Sbrigatevi
dobbiamo scappare
[Musica]
Oh sono troppo agitato ho paura che si
spegne
Non riesco ad aprirla Sì ce l'hai preso
scappa Anita aspetta un pochino
Ah ah ah ah ah
aspettati questo
aiutami aiutami
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Credo che questa sia una sfida la sfida
finale Sì è vero
Aiuto Aiutami l'amore
perché mi guardo
Ma sembra non gli facciano niente
perché si sta sparando con la scusa no
aspetta aspetta
oh no sta sparando i colori Ah lo scudo
ha detto dobbiamo trovare un altro modo
tranquillo Aspetta Rita provo ad
aiutarti io
sì perché sta utilizzando lo scudo
dobbiamo aspettare finché non toglie lo
scudo e una volta tolto lo possiamo
colpire Non sprecare i colpi adesso
andiamo
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
Bravo bravo
hai capito
[Musica]
funziona
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Guarda
è apparso il peggio Ed è scomparso il
poliziotto
[Applauso]
questa volta abbiamo completato assieme
perché il bruco Ma poi lasciate mi piace
se volete vederne altre e ora vi
lasciamo Qua quattro caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri video
cliccate su quella che preferite eh
Buona visione Ciao